comment ryan est il tombé dans ce puits
en fait en fait mardi dernier le 1er
février il y avait un gars en cinq ans
qui jouait avec son père par
inadvertance par accident il tombe dans
le puits dans un puits de presque 60 de
mètres de profondeur il était suspendu à
30,2 et la largeur de ce puits est de 45
cm donc son père avec sa famille ont
essayé de le sortir impossible donc ils
ont fait appel aux gens du village
impossible et un moment donné il y avait
un hashtag il faut sauver ryan et sera
hashtag s'est répandue comme une traînée
de poudre et c'est ce qui est fait que
les autorités marocaines se sont
mobilisés pour essayer de déplacer des
montagnes pour sortir un petit garçon né
et donc on a vécu c'est six jours avec
ce sous un tremblement de terre affectif
mondiale sssa l'importance de cette
expérience et moi dans mon expérience
j'ai eu peut-être un certain si je peux
comparer l'intensité semble affectif et
sentimental et est presque personnelle
on a eu le 11 septembre aux états unis
on a eu le bataclan et charlie hebdo en
france et puis ce moment là où tout le
monde se sont concernés par le destin de
quelqu'un et ryan a su réunir cette
unité sentimentale et affectif
internationale la preuve même le pape a
en a parlé les présidents de la répartie
et que nous savons alors c'est mardi
vers 14 heures que le petit ryan est
tombé dans un puits de plus de 32 mètres
de profondeur que son père est en train
de 2,2 en train de faire des paris le
père expliquait alors qu'ils s'étaient
ce qui s'était passé exprimé son
inquiétude regarder j'étais en train
d'essayer de réparer mon puig le puits
fait 32 mètres de profondeur et il est
venu près de moi il est tombé dans le
puits tout est allé vite je ne m'en suis
pas rendu compte j'ai pas dormi j'ai pas
fermé l'oeil de la nuit il est en bas et
moi je suis en haut je suis déchiré
sa mère est dans un état inimaginable et
moi aussi et on espère que d'ici cet
après midi on aura une bonne nouvelle la
police et les autorités n'ont pas arrêté
de nous aider je les remercie ils font
leur maximum et l'état nous aide comme
ils peuvent le peuple marocain entier
est avec nous je suis touché par cette
solidarité
alors immédiatement l'alerté donnée des
dizaines de secouristes sont alors
dépêchés sur les lieux mais ces derniers
seront content que l'opération sera bien
plus délicate que prévu le puits ne
mesure que ce 45 cm de large en son
sommet se rétrécit davantage vers le fou
impossible de sortir le petit par le
puits regarder s'ils ont dû faire pour
essayer de l'atteindre galles ryan joué
près de chez lui lorsqu'il est tombé
dans ce puits pour les secours la
manoeuvre est délicate dans cette cavité
étroite les tentatives de faire
descendre un sauveteur ont toutes échoué
tout seul une caméra glissé hier au fond
du puits a permis d'entrevoir ryan
vivant pour évacuer l'enfant bloqué à 32
mètres de profondeur dans un puits de 45
cm de large les secours ont entamé une
gigantesque opération de déblaiement il
s'apprête à creuser un tunnel de 3
mètres pour atteindre l'enfant
c'est
c'est très dur 1 et les images
insoutenables vraiment ce qu'est ce
qu'ils étaient enfin ce qui a accentué
la douleur marocaines et internationales
c'est que pendant ces journées là
pendant ces longues journées on savait
que l'enfant était encore vivant qu'il
respirait et donc s'adonner cette
souffrance international supportable et
est ce qui est assez fort a ajouté un
truc parce que là on a passé un bon bout
tu en as à faire du pour les réseaux
sociaux à faire du bashing à des halles
est critiqué parce qu'il charrie la
parole raciste la parole antisémite il
charrie beaucoup de choses qui ne sont
pas forcément positif là
particulièrement les réseaux sociaux ont
montré sûr qu'ils étaient très efficaces
qu'ils étaient capables de mobiliser la
conscience internationale les
volontaires l'international et donc les
réseaux sociaux là on était à l'origine
cette mobilisation internationale bon il
ya eu une fin triste et dramatique ça
mais quand même ramené un pays qui a
détruit qui a déplacé une montagne et on
a eu une attention internationale qui
s'est focalisé sur le sort de de ce
garçonnet et qui a mis en lumière les
problèmes de l'enfance et donc dé payer
comme une marque bien sûr alors alors
que le temps passant on a fait descendre
sachez le de l'eau de l'oxygène
au fond du puits grâce aux images d'une
caméra envoyée au fond du puits ce que
vous disais on apercevait le petit
garçon a faibli mais toujours en vie les
images sons sont très dures
vraiment c'est
c'est insupportable 1 où il valérie
alors je suis suffisamment vieille pour
me souvenir d'une autre affaire qui date
de 1985 d'une jeune fille omayra sanchez
en colombie dont on se souvient
peut-être tous des images pour les plus
âgés cette petite fille pareil qui avait
été comme ce petit garçon ensevelies
l on la voyait son visage mais voilà
voilà et on n'a pas également pas pu la
sauver ce visage m'avait hanté pendant
des mois et des mois et je pense que
pour ryan les images de ryan devons nous
hanter pendant des mois et des mois
encore illustré chez même pas si je
renonce
je préfère mettre cet élan de solidarité
dans le monde entier sur les réseaux ce
que vous disiez motifs sur place en
signe de soutien à la famille ariane
envers les soaps tout sauf sauveteurs
mobilisés ce roulage des milliers de
personnes ou entonné des chants est pris
et on priait à proximité du puits et
samedi aux alentours de 17 heures les
secouristes parviennent à pénétrer
jusqu'à la poche dans laquelle se trouve
ryan et c'est vers 22 heures qu'ils
parviennent à remonter le petit garçon
sur une civière et malheureusement à la
note brian n'a pas survécu gilles un nom
c'est épouvantable parce que vous le
disiez monsieur fort justement c'est
l'espoir avec la technologie on voit
tous les moyens mis en oeuvre c'est à
dire qu'effectivement il ya les
pelleteuses y aller secourir des
dizaines de gens et jusqu'au bout on a
cru qu'on allait pouvoir arriver jusqu'à
lui et même le roi du maroc s'en est ému
parce que c'est lui qui d'ailleurs après
a présenté les condoléances du peuple à
la famille c'est bouleversant c'est
juste faire juste juste une petite
explication pour comprendre pourquoi cet
élan international de solidarité parce
qu'à un moment donné chacun s'est senti
proche de 2,7 enfants on dirait le vôtre
on dirait le mien ont juré celui du
voisin donc elle est devenue non pas
l'enfant marocain qui était coincée sous
le puits mais l'enfant de tout le monde
que tout le monde espérait un miracle
qu'ils puissent sortir vivants mais
malheureusement s'installe n'était pas
mais ça reste ça reste une expérience ça
reste il ya une preuve qui a été donnée
qui a été qui est donné qu'on peut
déplacer les montagnes que la volonté
internationale la conscience
internationale compter les mobilisés par
les réseaux sociaux par les bons réseaux
sociaux ça peut donner des résultats
positif même si malheureusement et n'est
pas sorti vivant de ce taux de ce qu'on
va on va voir la sortie c'était donc
samedi vers 22 heures en rdc c'est dur
ils ont prié et espéré jusqu'au bout
avec eux un pays tout entier et bien au
delà mais vers 22 heures c'est le corps
sans vie de ryan ou que les sauveteurs
ont extrait du puits où il était tombé
mardi dernier
le roi mohamed 6 a exprimé à ses parents
sa compassion et dans le monde entier
des messages ont afflué en hommage au
petit garçon de cinq ans et aux efforts
rassemblés pour tenter de le sauver a
souligné benoît 16
au maroc comme et tout le monde s'est
rassemblé pour sauver ryan
tous les gens étaient là opérant pour
sauver un enfant
c'est c'est très dur hein alors le roi
du maroc avait même fait fermer les
autoroutes de près d'un quart du pays
pour que l'ambulance et le champ libre
quelques minutes plus tard c'est le choc
un vous savez des journées sur place
confirme que le corps de ryan qui a été
chargé dans l'ambulance et sans vie un
peu plus tard un peu plus tôt le roi
mohamed6 avait contacté les parents pour
leur présenter ses condoléances comme
vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui le petit
ryan a été inhumée dans son village et
c'était forcément moment très émouvant
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une très grosse pensée bien sûr pour
tout le peuple marocain qui a été
dévastée par cette affaire qui a duré
plusieurs jours on était plein d'espoir
un pour
tirana qui a fait mal c'est moi c'est ça
qui m'a fait le plus mal parce que moi
j'étais persuadé qu'il allait sans doute
j'écoutais des infos le mas d'azil reste
un maître du bon bah c'est bon tu un
petit père on l'a sauvé pour moi cette
voie là là de son lit percute que j'ai
pris c'est quand je n'y croyais pas sur
les réseaux sociaux quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai c'est pas possible je voyais ce ce
ballon avec je l'aï ryan avec le ballon
j'ai maintenant mais c'est quoi ce
délire j'y croyais pas j'ai vraiment
pris un uppercut
malgré tous les efforts qui ont été
faits pour moi il pour moi il était
sauvée pour moi et j'ai pas compris ce
qui s'est passé en fait est là qui
repose en paix si tu aimes bin oui moi
je trouve pas il ya eu un vrai élan de
solidarité c'est super j'ai été un peu
choqué quand même par le traitement
médiatique certaines images qu'on a vu
c'est pas si c'était nécessaire de les
montrer voilà l'image du prophète
iranienne qui est entre la vie et la
mort au fond du puits ça fait là je vais
pas vous le monde n'a pas voulu voir ses
complices étaient très dures de la
montre et je parlement après après c'est
chez pas moi ça me choque de voir les
caméras derrière son corps quand on
vient de le retrouver ça me choque voilà
je parle même pas des fausses cagnotte
que tu écris des marques de tee-shirts à
son effigie pendant qu'il était en
conseil
et de respect à lui et sa famille je
fait ça c'est la face sombre des réseaux
sociaux il ya des des gens qui ont
essayé d'exploiter ce drame pour se
faire de l'argent qui s'aggrave et les
ventes il ya eu des ventes de t-shirts à
l'effigié de ryan qui ont fait scandale
bien entendu grande écoute mais sans
mentir encore entre la vie et la mort
avec des mannequins souriantes c'est
n'importe quoi c'est qu'on peut pas
attaquer ça les gens comme ça qui font
ça c'est vrai que c'est fragile oui mais
il faut retrouver raymond c'est une
bonne question mais aurait retrouvé d'où
ça vient il faut retrouver les adresses
évidemment les gens ont prétexté mais il
ya des gens qui ont payé parce que
honnêtement quand on allait dessus on a
vraiment cru que c'est une collecte
organisée vraiment par l'état marocain
ou à la famille c'est parce qu'elle va
monstrueux ces monstres c'est pour ça
que les mapa à préciser plusieurs fois
qu'il n'y avait pas de cas notre
argent la peine qu'il a il a été obligé
lui même de préciser ça c'est hors alors
tout des milliers de personnes ont fait
part de leur émotion emmanuel macron
maïs ce soir je veux dire à la famille
du petit ryan et au peuple marocain que
nous partageons leur peine il ya ni
d'algos yannick jadot bien sûr
il ya aussi du rhin un jeune homme
aujourd'hui voilà il ya abderrazak
hamdallah qui a décidé d'offrir une
maison aux parents du défunt ryan joueur
de foot voilà c'est vrai que c'est il ya
un élan de solidarité incroyable et
c'est vrai que tous il ya eu tellement
de médiatisation de cette affaire on
était sûr que ça allait bien se terminer
et on était tous pendus à se dire qu'est
ce qui va se passer et c'est vrai qu'on
était sûr que ça laisse aller bien se
finir et le plus le plus douloureux vous
l'avez dit c'est de savoir que que le
petit ryan était vivant qu'on pouvait le
voir avec les caméras et vous pouvez
voir vous imaginer la souffrance c'est
parti les parents de la famille c c'est
dramatique puis sert il faut dire aussi
que le peuple marocain à qui il faut
rendre hommage ce soir qui s'est
mobilisé avec une grande force et qui a
montré que au moins on peut tout mettre
en oeuvre pour sauver une vie ça remet
en question un petit peu la valeur des
choses quand on a vécu les réfugiés
quand on a vécu les guerres les tensions
régionales se voir qu'un pays comme le
maroc puisse mobiliser pendant six jours
pour sauver un petit garçon ça donne de
l'espoir pour pour l'avenir et ça montre
un petit peu là la vérité vraie des
choses et des raies et de la vie en
général
tout